the game starts walking that went
quickly so this time a bit
easier to care for 2 180 the opponent has
another spaniard the spaniards
lost it's good
and is now sixth black is playing
more passively
we're probably learning our
closed catalan now it
looks like it b 6 came a little
earlier  or you can play it like that and
see if he has b76 in lausanne moves
to a6 taking the somewhat more active version
too much of course
unusual yes
probably both not bad
now pc or springer spokesman quotes
well good but after pcs themselves with
their center  get that ca
n't really be bad so
he could try b5 now but
I can even play c from it he goes
back well okay okay then the
center
was to be expected
so now the question is whether you
can do something tactically here ever
five players are already pulling g5
hangs b7 yes
probably wins material but
could lead to a somewhat tattered
position well
I am I'll try it out
so far so good yes well you can
take the quality or the smooth
knight yes of course the knights
whereby of course
you don't think it's particularly harmonious
here,
so it's not quite trivial,
especially since the bishop doesn't have great squares, it
could probably b7 more often, ten bishops b 7 b 8
and back again, the knight
beats e5 on that, i could but 11 14
but could play the three  try it
looks a bit stupid the three
so c3
times i don't think ok i have to
bring the runner back how then it goes
i can't just put five that
they look totally crooked
well of course he can of course
do that but the position is now  very
clear then runs straight into
the fortress so now has two
pawns for the piece
he quickly realized that yes it is
relatively easy now like 5 wins a
minimum of one more pawn and the pawn with
the three is now gone too and if he
hits the  three it would have been
a little tougher